هجره اكبر هجره هذه والله اكبر هجره ما
هجرنا من بلادنا مش هيك والله ما هو هيك
هجرنا من
بلادنا الله يكسر اللي كان السبب حجه
اليوم اليهود ايش ايش قالوا لكم اطلعوا هي
طلع ها شوفني على الكامرا لا بتقدر نمشي
ولا بنقدر نروح والله حرام يا رب والله
حرام يا رب من وين جاي انت في الاصل يا
حجه وال الشاطئ جايين وانا ه ساكنه واجوا
بناتي وكناين ويهم عن
هي مطف شو وين بدك تروح اليوم والله ماان
عارف وين نروحه مكان منيح مش عارفين وينفي
وسع ما فيش وسع وين نروح والله ما احنا
عارفين وين نروح يا اخوي الاكل والله يا
بني ما شايفينه هدول الليز والله ولا حدا
عطيهم حاجه هيهم ابصر 30 نفر عندهم 30 نفر
والله
حرام هيك ضرب وخبط وقتل ما بينفعش هذا
الكلام
والله ما بينفع هذا الكلام خلص اخذوا بياه
خص يشر الغلابه ايش هذا ماله ايش هذا
مالها كلهم
غلابه